es la primera confirmación oficial de
admin del jefe de acmi En todo caso que
son ellos que es al qaeda del que
retiene a Olivia hubo videos en los que
olivié el mismo decía que estaba
retenido pero vídeos en los que no se
hablaba directamente de los oficiales
aquí hay reconocimiento
el mismo dice hago una decepción y
respondo y me dirijo también a la
familia dice que las autoridades
francesas conocían de las condiciones en
las que Bolivia fue tomado como rehén y
que la puerta está abierta para las
negociaciones y reformula lo que también
me dijeron otras fuentes de acné Y es
que a Bolivia no se le puso una trampa
antes de ser secuestrado lo que es
importante porque hubo misivas para
decir que admin no podía invitar a
Olivia roboa para realizar una
entrevista con uno de sus jefes y luego
secuestrarlo Aquí él niega que sea el
grupo el que haya montado esta operación
de secuestro lo que pone término a estas
misivas que se enviaron para decir que
básicamente había un vicio de
procedimiento y que había que liberarlo
por eso pero lo que hay que retener es
que se abren las puertas a la
negociación y dice que el balón ahora
está en el campo de las autoridades
francesas